Hi! My name is Simone. I’m a UCLA freshman, and I’m here to introduce you to living on campus.
We are here on “The Hill.” That’s where undergraduates live at UCLA.
Here we are at the south end of The Hill.
This is De Neve Plaza.
The buildings here have tree or plant names, from A for Acacia through
H for Holly.
Here’s Holly. It’s where I live.
It’s the center of the universe.
Please! On the north end of The Hill is Sunset Village, with places like Canyon Point
and Courtside.
I live in Courtside.
It’s right by the tennis court.
Tennis is fun, but if that’s not your game, there’s a bunch of other things to do.
Like an outdoor gym.
Or basketball.
Or volleyball.
Or swimming.
In between De Neve Plaza and Sunset Village there’s a mixture
of new and updated buildings. For instance,
there are the three Riebers: Rieber Hall, Rieber Vista, and Rieber Terrace.
On The Hill, you’re never very far from central campus,
where your classes, libraries and student services are.
More than 90 percent of new students live on campus.
When you live here, you get oriented to campus life sooner.
The food is great, and you have a choice of four different restaurants here.
There’s a lot of variety here at Feast. My favorite is all the vegetarian options.
The best is the sushi.
But I love the flatbread.
You can even check your phone for the daily menu or nutritional facts.
If you want to!
This is a great place to live. Let’s go check out a room . . .
We have an award-winning dining program, and De Neve is one of the best.
Let me show you around.
The cafes are fun, too.
Some people hang out in their rooms, but there’s a whole student neighborhood,
with places to study and places to kick back.
It’s a lot of fun living on campus,
and it can help you do better academically.
Plus there’s over 5,000 events every year happening right here on The Hill.
If you visit campus, be sure to take a housing tour,
and see for yourself. See you here soon!